Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan.
Although you may know me from across the
Internet as Rawkode.
Today, I'm going to guide you through Komodor.
If you're not familiar with Komodor,
it is a SaaS based product to help
you troubleshoot and debug your Kubernetes clusters,
Something
I have a few opinions about.
And I don't often cover SaaS based products.
However, Komodor just this week
announced
their new free tier, meaning you don't need
to pay to get started with Komodor.
Not only that, Komodor sponsored my time to
produce the advanced scheduling demo
and lastly,
they've also committed to being on an episode
of clustered I'm going to put them through
the tests. I'm going to give them a
broken cluster
and they're convinced they can use Komodor to
fix it.
So thank you Komodor for sponsoring the advanced
scheduling video.
I'm sorry and thank you for joining me
on clustered very, soon.
But today let's focus on the tutorial and
show you how you can get started with
Komodor.
We're going to start from the beginning
but also showcase some advanced use cases for
Komodor.
But the first thing we need to do
is go to commodore.com.
From here you can feel free to read
the marketing material, go to resources,
pricing, documentation,
whatever you want.
I'm gonna start by logging in
which I use my Google account.
So immediately we're presented with the service list.
This is a list of all of the
micro services or
maybe huge services, who knows, deployed to your
Kubernetes cluster.
Now you won't see this list straight away,
this is because I've already added my first
Kubernetes cluster.
But let me walk you through the process
for doing that yourself.
Down at the bottom left you will see
the integrations button.
When you select this you can click on
add a cluster.
You can give it whatever name you want
and hit next.
This will give you the command that you
copy and run-in your terminal. It will add
a Helm repository,
deploy the Helm chart with a Komodor agent,
and then you click next where it will
wait for the connection and confirm it.
From there go back to the home page
and you'll see your Kubernetes services from your
cluster.
Now there's a couple of nice things on
this page right off the bat. First,
all my services are healthy.
But secondly,
we get a good overview of the workloads
running in this cluster.
You can see I have a bunch of
Prometheus stuff.
I've got one password connect,
Weave GitOps,
cert manager, shop at I,
lots of cool stuff.
Now if things weren't all healthy, we could
either exclude
the healthies
or we could filter on the healthies.
If you have more than one cluster,
you can filter by that too.
And if you only want to take a
look at particular namespace,
in my case, let's just take a look
at my community namespace.
You'll see that I'm only running a single
service.
If I want to view the platform and
the community namespace, I can do so as
well.
If you want to filter by workload type,
we can click on daemon set and see
daemon sets.
Just the basic settings that you would expect
from a service overview of your cluster.
The last thing I'll point out on this
page is at the top right.
Here we can sort by a few options.
By default is on health which makes sense,
if there's something that is unhealthy in your
cluster you want to see that first. The
other view that I've been enjoying over the
last few days is namespace.
This is a good way to break it
down by namespace without specifically filtering on a
namespace itself.
And if you're only worried about things that
have changed recently, go to last modified and
you'll see the most recent resources that have
been modified within your cluster.
I deployed Prometheus today, so we can see
Prometheus
front and center.
And that's the service overview. It's not life
changing,
but it's very valuable
with just enough functionality
to maybe pry cube control out of your
hands when things go wrong.
So let's see what else we can do
with Komodor.
So we also have the jobs option on
the left. Although I have no jobs on
my cluster, however this is just the same
as services, if you are using the job
object or the cron job object you will
see them listed here.
Next we have the events,
this will show you all the events from
your Kubernetes cluster.
Now this is something that can be typically
quite overwhelming
to do from the kubectl command line
because events
come fast and furious in the Kubernetes cluster.
And when we have an abundance of information,
bring in a visual layer
to that information
is how we develop understanding.
So let's see how we can understand the
events within a Kubernetes cluster with Komodor.
Much like the service page, we have the
ability to filter these events on cluster and
namespace.
However, now we can filter by individual service.
We can filter by the event type.
We have the ability to filter on the
status of the event as well as deploy
details and availability reasons.
And we'll get into more of these in
just a moment.
But first, let's take a look at my
platform namespace.
Now here we can see all the events
as Komodor was deployed to my cluster and
went through the discovery phase. That is discovering
all the workloads and resources within my cluster.
From here, we can click on a service
name.
So that slides out at a nice kind
of popover model dialogue meaning that we don't
really lose our original context when we're debugging
which I think is really important for debugging
tool. So very nice addition.
We have the service name, the health status,
can see all the events for the service,
as well as the pods,
the notes are scheduled on,
and some additional information which gives us access
to the labels and annotations on
the service.
Okay. Let's pop in to the monitor namespace
and we'll select our Grafana service.
Currently, we only see information about Grafana,
which we'd expect.
We can see the events,
again the nodes,
pods
and our labels and annotations.
Now before we take a look at the
best practice recommendations, let's pop back over to
events
and see here we have the related resources
button.
Now this is quite nice because it allows
us to select other resources within the same
namespace
and we want to be able to collectively
group them and view their events together.
So I'll pick on Kubernetes services,
and I'll mark this as related.
I'll pop over to config maps, where I'll
select the API server one, and I'll pick
one more, which is to pop over to
secret and sacred fan out config.
We apply the selection and now you'll see
that the events listed for this resource include
their related resources.
Now I think this feature could be improved.
I'd love to see
scan the YAML for
reference config maps, secrets and and services with
matching selectors
and hook this up for me. However, doing
it manually for those few resources that I
do want to group collectively
isn't exactly at the end of the world.
It's a cool feature and one that could
have some really interesting improvements over time.
So let's go back to the information screen
and we'll see these best practice warnings.
So when we click this, we have a
bunch of checks and here we can see
that our deployment has one replica.
Now this is a warning just because if
we lose that replica, we've lost our service.
So maybe you want to run two or
three.
However, you know your services
better than any tool can. So feel free
to use the ignore button.
For Grafana, maybe we determine that we do
only ever want one and we're happy for
that to be offline if something goes wrong.
We can just say ignore for fourteen days,
thirty days, ninety days or forever.
So perhaps I'm not ready to make a
decision on whether this is good or bad
yet and I'll ignore it for a couple
of weeks.
Next we have a critical warning telling us
that this workload has no liveness probe.
If we expand it, it tells us
that liveness probes are sustained to ensure that
an application stays on a healthy state. When
a liveness probe fails, the pod will be
restarted.
This is a pretty neat behavior, the Kubelet
monitors our workloads and if it needs to
kick them, it kicks them.
So you should always try and have some
of these best practices whenever possible and Komodor
brings up front and center.
So I'm not going to ignore that one
because you know what, I should have a
liveness probe in this workload.
Now we've got some past ones here where
we have a readiness probe, we have CPU
and memory constraints
and the last warning is just the pull
policy.
It's not good practice to have an image
pull policy of always.
Usually preferred to set it to if not
present, it just means when a work remotely
starts, you don't need to go to an
image registry and see if it can be
pulled down and it usually means you're using
some sort of alias tag system.
Again, we want to kind of get away
from that as much as possible.
So it's not a critical but it is
a warning that you maybe you need to
update this.
And I think this is a nice way
to gain more insights and understanding of the
services within our cluster.
So let's see what else we can do
from the events page.
So I'm not gonna filter on an individual
service. I don't think that shows anything new,
but if we scroll down we could filter
on the event type.
So let's filter by one of these event
types and see what information we get back.
Let's start with one of the most common
ones which is config change.
This is going to tell you when a
conflict map is created, modified or deleted within
your cluster.
So
let's create one.
Here I have cm. Yml, which is a
ConfigMap called Rawkode.
When we go to the terminal,
we can apply this to our monitoring namespace.
Let's make a quick change to this conflict
map and say that we no longer want
key value, instead
we want
name
David.
Go to our terminal,
apply this one more time,
and let's go visualize this with Komodor.
So right away, we can see
that a ConfigMap was created in the monitor
namespace called Rawkode.
We click on this, we have all green
because it was the first time this ConfigMap
was created.
We then have our change. And this time
we can see that the key value was
removed and name David was added.
And if you want to view this in
more details, you can expand the depth.
We can see the data changed
along with some metadata about the resource as
well.
This is one of these really simple but
very valuable features.
When things go wrong on a Kubernetes cluster,
it's not because the resources haven't changed, it's
because of our changes that things sometimes go
wrong. Human error is probably still the biggest
cause of problems on a Kubernetes cluster.
So it's crucial that you understand
when config changes in your cluster and how
that can have a cascading effect on the
workloads within your cluster.
And your ability to see those changes as
they happen
will substantially lower your mean time to recovery.
So beyond config change,
let's filter
on availability issues.
Now availability issues give us an understanding of
when a workload was unavailable.
Perhaps because the pod was being restarted or
the probes were failing.
If we take a look at the Grafana
one here,
you can see that pod was unhealthy and
why was unhealthy? Well,
it was container creating.
Of course it's not healthy if it's just
creating.
Also what's nice here is it shows you
each of the containers and the status for
them too.
If you want, you can click the live
pods and logs button.
This will show us the current pod and
our cluster for that selector
where we could pop it open and go
to logs. So it's nice having our logs
right front and center when required.
If we pop back to details,
we can see the conditions
that tells if our pod is healthy.
We have the containers, the images are running,
the pull policy, the ports, the mounts and
arguments,
all the useful information that you need.
We have the ability to see the tolerations,
the volumes
and of course the events associated with this
workload.
If you're a fan of the kubectl describe
command, you can click describe and get the
exact output on the screen as so.
So to reiterate from the events page, we've
seen a pod with availability issues.
We went to the current instance of this
pod, we've seen there was no problem and
we had all the information we need to
debug a problem.
To debug if there was something wrong.
Now the rest of the Komodor UI is
pretty much more of the same.
We can break down all of the resources.
We can see nodes. We can click on
a node.
We can see all of its conditions,
the capacity,
and allocatable resources
across CPU, memory, storage, etcetera.
We have the ability to cordon and drain
a node if we wish.
For workloads, it's the same. We have deployments.
We can click. We can edit. We can
scale. We can restart.
You can do this for most of the
resources within your cluster.
For storage, we can see storage classes.
For config, we go to config maps.
And we can see them.
Pretty much, you're getting a visual representation
of everything you can do with the kubect
ectl command.
We can even list the custom resource definitions
within our cluster
and search.
So I'm not going to spend any more
time going through this
because these webpages are dashboards
and as we all know dashboards are not
to be looked at until something goes wrong.
So how do we get information from Komodor
to give us alerts when our attention is
needed?
And for that we have monitors.
We can expand our cluster
and we can see that we have some
rules already in place. These are shipped by
default by Komodor.
We have an availability monitor. This will let
us know if any of our workloads are
less than 80% for more than ten seconds.
If we need 10 pods on a deployment
and for more than ten seconds, we have
seven or less, we'll get an alert.
If our cron jobs are failing, we get
an alert.
We can get alerts for when deployments are
updated
and we can also get alerts for when
our nodes are not healthy.
So let's take a look at one of
these alerts and then configure our own.
Here is the deployment alert. This is going
to let us know whenever a workload is
modified within our cluster.
Using the integrations that you have configured with
Komodor,
you can use these as destinations. We
can use a standard webhook or publish a
message to Slack.
I have a channel called SRE
and I'm going to click save.
So now if we modify a deployment, we
should get a notification
to my Slack channel.
So let's test it. I have my Slack
here, but first we need a deployment change.
So I'm just going to do this through
the Komodor UI.
I'm gonna go to deployments,
and we'll modify the cert manager deployment.
We can click on edit YAML,
where I'm just going to add a new
label.
We hit apply,
we can see that we have new events
and we can see that our manual action
to edit a deployment,
we click on it, we see the change.
So even though we can see the deployment
changed here, this will not trigger a Slack
notification
because it uses the resources generation
rather than a resource version.
Which is good because
that we really need a notification that a
label changed on a workload when the workload
itself is not restarted, rescheduled, or modified.
Now let's make one more change to our
resource.
This time we're going to add an environment
variable,
which is going to have a value
of high.
Now this will trigger
a new generation.
And if we pop over to Slack,
we'll see the notification and the SRE channel.
And if we click on this, it takes
us directly
to the event with the change.
We can see that the revision and generation
of this
resource went from one to two because of
an environment variable addition.
This workload
change is also denoted here by the new
deployment which tells us that the image doesn't
change but
other aspects did.
So given that we have a pretty sophisticated
troubleshooting and debugging tool here,
it's also worth noting that Komodor has
pretty elevated
privileged access to your cluster
and as such we need to be able
to trust it.
Luckily, Komodor provided the ability
to protect some of our more sensitive information
from being leaked through the Komodor UI.
Let's go to resources,
workloads, and pods.
If I select the default namespace,
I have a new super secret workload.
If we click on this, there's not a
lot to see here, but if we go
to the logs, we have
a password.
How do we prevent Komodor from leaking such
information?
Now it doesn't have to be just an
or standard out logging although when applications crash
sometimes they do dump the environment revealing very
sensitive information
but also how do we redact this from
config maps and other sources of sensitive information.
Fortunately by default Komodor hashes all the information
that it pulls from secret resources
But we do need to put in a
couple of extra steps to protect standard IO
and our config maps. Although I hope you're
not storing too much sensitive information in a
config map.
And I'm gonna configure this
through the Commodore UI.
So the first thing we want to do
is to go to configuration and config maps
where I can select the Commodore namespace.
Here we have the Kubernetes watcher config
and I'm going to go straight to the
edit page.
You'll see we have two settings here on
lines twenty and twenty one called redact and
redact logs.
These take a list of expressions to redact
from Kubernetes resources and from log data.
Now this accepts regex
pattern matching like you can do with any
sophisticated login library
but I'm going to keep it very simple
for this demo.
I'm going to explicitly say that I want
my password one two three omitted
and we'll add one more.
This time we'll do a regex match for
anything that looks like password equals
then we'll open a matcher to dot star
and we'll stick a space on the end.
So now we will have to kick the
Komodor agent
so that reloads its configuration.
We can just delete.
And, already, we can see we have a
new one running.
So let's go back to our pod and
the default namespace
where we have our super secret
workload.
And if we view the logs,
our password one two three has been redacted.
So let's modify this
at the deployment level
where we can say edit YAML.
And we have password one two three, but
let's also add password equals
hello
not secret like so.
We'll cause this pod, which we can see
here, to be terminated with a new one
running.
And if we pop open the logs for
here,
we can see that both values
have been properly redacted.
So this is a very important feature,
but also a very cumbersome feature
because security is hard. It's never easy.
It would probably be worthwhile for your team
or organization to have convention
to, well, not log sensitive values.
But if you do, always make sure there's
some marker in place
so you can configure tools like Komodor and
other logging systems
to redact that information as fast as possible.
And
you can even run the container locally to
test your redactions before pushing them to your
Kubernetes cluster.
Let's take a look.
If I go to my terminal,
I have a just fail.
It's like a make fail. However, it allows
positional arguments on targets
and is generally just a little bit nicer
to work with.
From here we can see redact and you
can already see the autocomplete here in the
documentation from the just file but we provide
a redaction phrase
and a logline.
I'm gonna say this redact raw code
and then the logline that I wanna test
is to say I am raw code
beer me type.
This pulls down the container image,
does a little bit of plumbing and then
shows you the input log and output and
you can see what it was before and
after the redaction.
This means that you can test your regex
patterns all you want.
Say you want to do password
equals
dot star
question mark
Rawkode because maybe we got it wrong
and then in our test
we'll do password
equals
blah raw
code without any.
Now this won't redact, but we have a
problem. We can fix it.
So let's run that again with the e
on the end
and oh shit, it's still broken.
Well clearly, don't know how to spell Rawkode.
There we go. We did do it right.
It works.
That string was redacted because we were able
to test the regex.
Well, that's it's really cool. You can actually
plumb in a shell script a whole bunch
of example log lines that you have from
your application with redactions that you know always
have to be satisfied
and hook this into your CI system and
that way you know right away whenever you've
got secrets leaking that should be redacted.
So that's a quick overview of Komodor.
There's an awful lot to love and it
gives you great visibility into the wonderfully complex
system that is Kubernetes running our wonderfully complex
applications which are our microservices.
This is just part one, there's going to
be a part two of this video dropping
early next week.
In part two we'll be taking a look
at more of the Komodor integrations.
We will see in how to integrate your
source control via GitHub.
We'll also take a look at hooking up
to Sentry for exception tracking
and Grafana and Alert Manager
giving you full visibility across all of your
observability
stack.
And then at the end of next week,
part three will drop where we take a
look at two final features. One, the humble
webhook and how we can get information from
Komodor to do whatever the hell we please.
And then one of my favorite features,
the vCluster integration.
Deploying Komodor to all your virtual clusters
and multitenant Kubernetes environments.
We'll be back next week with the next
video. Until then, have a wonderful day, and
I'll see you all soon.